le roman de Lula documentaire réalisé
par José Bourgarel ou le portrait d'un
homme vous venez de le voir au destin
réellement extraordinaire dont le
parcours syndical est politique aura
aussi épousé l'histoire de son pays
pendant 3/4 de siècle le tel un phénix
Renaissance sans cesse de ses cendres
Lula vient donc d'être élu pour la
troisième fois à la tête du Brésil quel
défi l'attendre désormais pour ce qui
pourrait être son dernier acte sur la
scène politique brésilienne nous allons
en débattre maintenant en compagnie de
nos invités présents sur ce plateau de
débat doc en commençant par vous Mocho
bienvenue vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de l'histoire contemporaine
du Brésil vous enseignez à l'université
Gustave Eiffel vous êtes également qu'au
présidente du réseau européen pour la
démocratie au Brésil et vous avez
codirigé entre autres cet ouvrage mon
cher Loula lettre à un président en
détention publié chez Anna Mozart avec
également cristaux Ventura bienvenue
bonjour vous êtes directeur de recherche
à l'IRIS l'Institut de relations
internationales et stratégique bien
entendu en charge de son programme
Amérique latine Caraïbes et vous êtes
l'auteur quant à vous de géopolitique de
l'Amérique latine 40 fiches pour
comprendre le monde c'est un ouvrage
qu'on peut se procurer chez eyrol et
puis enfin avec nous Erika Campello
bienvenue vous êtes co-fondatrice et
co-président de l'association autre au
Brésil c'est une association fondée
maintenant voilà 20 ans et qui s'est
donné pour but de décrypter les enjeux à
la fois sociétaux politiques brésilien
pour le public francophone
on va revenir après ce documentaire
entièrement consacré au parcours de de
Lula parcours extraordinaire réellement
sur un plan personnel sur un plan
syndical sur un plan politique on va
revenir tout de même sur sa dernière
élection c'était le 30 octobre dernier
30 octobre 2022 où il l'emporte face à
Jayer bolsonaro mais il l'emporte d'une
très courte tête avec
50,9% des suffrages il est investi à la
tête du Brésil le premier janvier
dernier et stupéfaction le 8 janvier
autrement dit 7 jours plus tard les
partisans de Jerry bolsonaro envahissent
à la fois le Congrès la Cour suprême et
le palais présidentiel de plan alto qui
se trouve bien entendu à Brasilia
première réaction
est-ce qu'à la suite de ces événements
très intenses du côté du Brésil on peut
dire aujourd'hui que la démocratie
brésilienne est sauvée à tenu le coup ou
est-ce que il y a encore un doute sur ce
simple sujet compte tenu de ce qui s'est
passé
ce qui est clair c'est que les 49% de
Brésiliens qui ont continué après un
mandat quand même catastrophique après
des menaces contre les institutions de
la République ont voté quand même pour
Jay bolsonaro ils ont pas disparu et en
partie ce sont ce sont des citoyens qui
sont radicalisés dans leur adhésion à un
agenda qui a un agenda extrémiste et un
désamour un des aveux complet à l'égard
des institutions et donc c'est c'est
brésilienne c'est brésilien il s'agit
pas des 49% des gens qui sont disposés à
la violence mais il y en a des milliers
voire des dizaines de milliers et pour
partie ce sont aussi des citoyens qui
sont à l'intérieur de l'État à
l'intérieur des forces de sécurité des
polices de l'armée et toute cette le
bolsonarisme a infiltré
l'armée l'administration une partie de
l'état c'est ce que vous êtes une grande
partie d'une grande partie de l'armée
c'était quelque chose dont on avait
conscience du fait que il y aurait une
opinion publique très difficile à
réintégrer dans un jeu politique qui se
font sur le plus réalisme sur le
consensus c'est une toute une partie de
la population déteste ou là considère
que la gauche ou le centre gauche ne
sont pas des adversaires politiques mais
des ennemis de la nation donc il y a
cette opinion là et aussi un état qui
s'est militarisé qui s'est radicalisé et
qu'il va être très difficile pour la
nouvelle administration de faire revenir
dans un chemin véritablement légaliste
il s'agit pas d'adhérer à leur jardin du
nouvel objectif mais simplement que les
les institutions jouent leur rôle et en
particulier les institutions de sécurité
elle a fait preuve de sa bonne santé du
coup
cette démocratie brésilienne et c'est
vrai qu'au soir du du 30 octobre dernier
il y avait quand même des doutes cette
question vu les résultats obtenu bah
disons que pour comprendre le film du 8
janvier faut se rappeler qu'on est dans
un pays qui connaît une crise
démocratique depuis en fait depuis 2016
au minimum depuis le ce que certains
considérait être le coup d'État à
parlementaire contre l'ancienne
présidente d'ilmar Rousset on parle d'un
pays dont la démocratie a subi plusieurs
pressions la première c'est ce coup
d'État parlementaire la seconde c'est un
gouvernement non élu qui a gouverné deux
ans au pays puis l'élection 2018 à
laquelle de laquelle a été éliminée
judiciairement Lula qui devait
normalement être déjà candidat peut-être
président en 2018 et puis ce dernier
développement qui montre une société
fracturée en fait une société qui est
polarisée avec deux blocs qui à peu près
représentent la même chose et
effectivement sur fond d'une énorme
défiance politique on ne croit plus à la
politique on ne croit plus à l'état dans
un pays qui connaît une crise sociale
économique terrible depuis ces années
2010 et c'est tout ce mélange en fait
qui crée disons cette crise démocratique
du Brésil n'est pas encore sorti mais
effectivement et si on compare à
d'autres pays à être américains les
institutions brésiliennes sont plutôt
résistantes et ont montré que il y avait
une capacité à conserver la légalité
dans la séquence actuelle et le fait que
Le président Lula est plus juste après
les événements du 8 janvier rallier à sa
cause l'ensemble des institutions
brésiliennes des gouverneurs des états
du Tribunal suprême fédéral la Cour
suprême et du Congrès dans lequel il y a
beaucoup d'adversaires qui sont présents
de Lula on va revenir ils sont tous là
avec lui ça montre quand même qu'il y a
aussi une aspiration à la consolidation
démocratique dans ce pays qui reste
vivante fort heureusement
Erica Campello c'est très difficile de
dire qu'il a la situation elle aura mal
au Brésil ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
le gouvernement de Lula est
angoissablement des coalitions il a plus
des 10 partis politiques qui commencent
à la au centre droit jusqu'à quasiment
crème gauche donc il va falloir composer
avec une avec cette richesse de partie
cette diversité qui ont des intérêts
très différents donc on peut pas dire
qu'il a démocratie est venue à la
normale parce que comme on disait
Christophe là depuis 2016 le Brésil vit
une période déception de raymocratique
ou la démocratie était attaquée à chaque
instant et en 2016 ça a permis quand
même des lire bon son âge c'était un
début quand même de c'est qu'on dit au
Brésil on a ouvert la la boîte de
Pandore et bossuna lui tous les fascisme
et toute cette extrême droite
brésilienne dure elle est sortie de là
il a notre processus démocratique il a
été fragilisé il est encore fragilisé
pourquoi parce que le 8 janvier était
une tragédie annoncée on savait que ça
allait arriver depuis le 30 octobre tout
cette partie de la population c'est 49%
qui ont voté pour beau son arbre était
une bonne partie
vous sentez des vents les casernes de
l'armée qui est-ce qui aurait dû faire
l'armée arrêter ça tout de suite et
pendant deux mois l'armée la police
militaire ont laissé faire une partie
des institutions de l'État brésilien
donc on ne peut pas dire qui tout est
réglé au contraire comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure l'État brésilien est
contaminé par le beau saunaïsme et
aujourd'hui nous l'a doit faire
l'équilibriste l'équilibrisme
c'est-à-dire il faut composer avec la
diversité aujourd'hui des personnes qui
soutiennent son gouvernement il faut pas
oublier qu'il a deux ministres qui ont
été le ministre de la Défense et le
ministre des communications au Brésil
qui sont des supporters des soutiens de
bossonnables et qui louenta a dû les a
ajouté à son gouvernement donc là-dessus
on n'est pas encore sorti dans un dans
un état déstabilité démocratique au
Brésil et je tiens à dire et à préciser
il alerter ça c'est le début le 8
janvier c'était un début
en début une continuation des
instabilité politique démocratique au
Brésil il faut que les gouvernements
internationaux le gouvernement français
l'Europe reste vigilante le gouvernement
de la reste encore fragilisé et donc on
doit vraiment faire très très attention
pour la suite parce qu'il a 4 ans devant
lui on est même pas encore au centre
premier jour de son mandat
tout ne lui est pas actif finalement
alors il faut se souvenir que tout ne
lui était pas acquis déjà au cours de
ces deux premiers mandats il était déjà
à la tête d'une coalition il ne
gouvernait pas seulement avec son propre
parti le Parti des travailleurs et le
Parti des Travailleurs n'a jamais eu la
majorité seule et il était loin de
l'avoir au Congrès il était obligé et
c'est le système brésilien qui le veut
de gérer ce qu'on appelle le
présidentialisme coalition c'est-à-dire
le fait d'avoir la majorité des
électeurs qui votent pour un programme
présidentiel et ce président va avoir à
mettre d'accord de très nombreux parties
on parle d'une quinzaine de parties
et donc il y a eu un jeu politique déjà
très compliqué qui a associé le centre
un centre qu'on appelle physiologique
c'est-à-dire qui salit au plus offrant
en terme de poste en terme d'avantage et
c'est déjà comme ça que Lula a gouverné
la différence principale que je vois
maintenant c'est que effectivement la
coalition doit aller beaucoup plus loin
parce que ce que Lula a dû constituer
c'est une sorte de front antifasciste
une union nationale pour avoir les
forces d'affronter ce que cette forme de
Néo fascisme qu'est le bolsonarisme
avait mis en oeuvre pour demeurer au
pouvoir souvent quand on regarde les
élections le deuxième tour d'octobre
depuis la France depuis l'Europe il y
avait une forme de déception ah le
progressisme gagne mais de peu donc
c'était un petit peu décevant mais
revenir au pouvoir par la voix des urnes
quand l'adversaire est prête à tout pour
manipuler l'opinion pour empêcher les
électeurs d'accéder aux urnes comme ça a
été le cas d'utiliser l'argent de l'État
pour acheter à tous les niveaux de
l'état des personnels politiques pour
faire pression la même chose dans les
entreprises affronter ça avec simplement
les voies de la légalité c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire et donc le fait
que Lula est plus gagné à la régulière
si vous voulez bolsonaro en octobre
c'est déjà quelque chose
d'extraordinaire mais
ça nécessite ensuite d'avoir affronter
ce qu'il en reste et quand vous posiez
la question de les institutions
ont-elles tenu le 8 janvier montre-t-il
que les institutions ont tenues le 8
janvier montre que une partie des
institutions ont tenues le judiciaire la
Cour suprême a tenu à jouer son rôle les
instances fédérales des États ont joué
leur rôle y compris des démonstrations
de force symbolique et le juge janvier a
montré aussi que les institutions sont
grevées de bolsonarismes y compris comme
m'a dit Madame Campello l'armée qui est
majoritairement
défiante à l'égard du gouvernement au
point que Lula n'a pas vraiment pu
choisir son ministre de la Défense il a
dû prendre un représentant du parti
militaire qui donc va être un quelqu'un
avec qui il va falloir composer qui ne
sera pas un allié de Lula nécessairement
s'il existe des fortes tensions avec les
militaires et il y en aura et il a un
savent pas savoir faire puisque vous
nous disiez que c'est pas la première
fois qu'il y a la tête d'une coalition
il sera à nouveau réconcilier cette
quinzaine de partis politiques pour
mener à bien son programme alors je
crois qu'il y a plusieurs choses la
première c'est que il y a personne
d'autre que Lula qui était en mesure de
pouvoir disons vaincre bolsonaro aux
élections 2022 et ce qui a fait que Lula
a pu vaincre c'est son équation
personnelle c'est sa surface personnelle
et c'est cette qualité que vous signalez
de conciliateur je crois vraiment que
moyenne de Lula c'est un négociateur
c'est syndicaliste il a c'est ça le
négociateur c'est le mot clé qu'on
retrouve effectivement
et c'est ce qu'il aime ce qui aime Lula
c'est effectivement
négocier trouver des points d'équilibre
et maintenir tenir des des paramètres
qui est naturellement ne marcheraient
pas ensemble je crois que c'est
fondamentalement ce qu'il est il porte
cela et c'est ce qui a marqué toute sa
vie politique depuis les grèves de 1980
jusqu'à ces élections il a toujours
fonctionné comme ça et donc j'ai envie
de dire que le défi aujourd'hui est à la
mesure du personnage qui va peut-être
faire effectivement un dernier mandat
qui sera le plus difficile pour lui de
ce point de vue là d'ailleurs il est le
premier à le dire c'est ce qu'il a dit
le soir de sa victoire c'est que ça va
être le mandat le plus difficile alors
pourquoi le plus difficile parce que la
société brésilienne est une fois de plus
fracturée elle est divisée elle est pas
du tout unie elle est polarisée
radicalisée donc ça c'est la réalité de
ce pays dans lequel s'affrontent des
courants très puissants très très
opposés antagonie vous avez des courants
très progressistes des secteurs qui
demandent de la reconnaissance de droits
individuels collectif comme les secteurs
indigènes afrodescendants LGBT etc la
Genèse brésilienne qui vient qui pointe
le bout de son nez au bout de ce quart
de premier de premier quart de 21e
siècle puis de l'autre côté vous avez un
Brésil conservateur traditionneliste
voire réactionnaire religieux sous un
mode parfois assez fondamentaliste parmi
les évangéliques par exemple et tout ça
en quelque sorte c'est le Brésil de de
2020 donc est-ce qu'il a toutes les
cartes en main ben non il a pas toutes
les cartes en main il a tout ce qu'il a
réussi à construire et c'était sa
stratégie c'était pour vaincre bolsonaro
il faut construire un Front démocratique
pour en fait mobiliser tous ceux qui
sont pour que le Brésil reste dans
l'État de droit et reste une démocratie
face à un projet autoritaire qui peut
amener une dérive de type fascisante
c'était sa stratégie jaloux là qui
d'ailleurs à l'époque on le rappeler
à coaguler tous les Antibes sonores en
réalité d'ailleurs ça faisait pas
l'unanimité dans son propre corps et il
a dû élargir élargir il a réussi à faire
cela il a ça pour lui aujourd'hui et
cette aspiration quand même à maintenir
le Brésil dans la démocratie est forte
dans ce pays mais il a pas toutes les
clés parce que il y a plein de choses
qui peuvent se passer et la question
militaire était une des grandes
questions cette élection parce que on
savait que certains disaient va-t-il y
avoir un coup d'État pour l'élection de
Lula certains moi par exemple je disais
ben non il y aura pas de coup d'état
parce que l'armée est déjà au pouvoir au
Brésil avec bolsonaro la question c'est
quelle place elle va laisser à Loula
autour de la table une fois que ce
dernier serait élu démocratiquement et
c'est exactement la question qui est
posée aujourd'hui et cette question là
on n'a pas toutes les clés pour y
répondre on va le découvrir déjà lu là
depuis le 8 janvier a commencé à limoger
des militaires des officiers mais il
veut comme toujours ne pas être dans une
un rapport frontal ou une purge
intégrale de l'institution militaire il
veut trouver un terrain d'accord et
aujourd'hui on est plutôt là-dedans donc
je pense que l'approche loup là c'est
une hypothèse sera un peu gradualiste
avec les militaires si ils arrivent à
respecter le jeu alors ça devrait
fonctionner si ça part ailleurs je crois
que Lula a quand même les moyens
aujourd'hui de pouvoir taper du point
sur la table aussi mais ça on le verra
au cours des mois qui suivront sa le
début de sa présidence vous souhaitiez
ajouter quelque chose avec quelqu'un
d'abord la question de l'armée aussi
Lula il a fait quelque chose après le 8
janvier très importantes il a déjà
remplacé 50 dirigeantes de l'armée
brésilienne mais l'armée c'est un
problème au Brésil mais malheureusement
pas le sol la question des polices
militaires les polices d'État parce que
au Brésil la police elle dépend des
gouver des états fédéraux il sait
polissent là elles sont aujourd'hui une
faction au Brésil elle sont complètement
gangrénées par la violence par la
corruption et par le bossonnalisme et
par le fascisme
soutenu beau sauna pendant ces quatre
dernières années c'est une police
extrêmement violente qui tue qui ont le
pouvoir des vies est mort sur la vie des
citoyens surtout les citoyens des
périphériques les plus vulnérables au
Brésil et souvent malheureusement sont
les personnes noires au Brésil mais
pourquoi je dis ça parce que c'est un
point important dans la démocratie
brésilienne et dans les stabilité du
gouvernement Lula mais ça va ce n'est
pas le sol nous la aura besoin aussi
pour continuer à gouverner du soutien
des mouvements sociaux et de la société
civile brésilienne il était élu grâce à
ça et ce n'est pas pour rien qu'il a
créé en premier ministère de peuple
autochtones avec la députée à sa tête il
y a un ministère sur l'égalité raciale
avec la sœur de la conseillère
municipale des Rio qui a été assassiné
en 2018 Marielle Franco c'est très
symbolique et cette politique et cette
bataille de la du symbolisme aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui au Brésil il est essentiel
pour changer les caps de la société
essayez de réconcilier la société
brésilienne c'est la première chose que
nous la doit réconcilier une dernière
petite chose qui est importante aussi de
noter le Brésil le beau saunaïsme fait
partie d'un mouvement conservateurs de
outre à droite d'extrême droite
internationale le fils de Botswana
Edward broussonnade pendant les
dernières cinq ans il a participé à plus
de 70 réunions aux États-Unis avec les
leaders de la droite dure donc il a un
projet qui menace la démocratie
brésilienne mais pas seulement nos
démocraties en Europe nous démocraties
en France notre démocratie en France
donc il faut vraiment faire très
attention si un mouvement qui est là qui
est fort et qui est consolidé on va voir
un extrait du documentaire si vous en
êtes d'accord c'est un meeting auquel
participe Lula dans le cadre de cette
toute dernière campagne présidentielle
et les noces et les Noirs
en meeting à l'occasion donc de cette
toute dernière campagne présidentielle
il a perdu un petit peu de voix
évidemment mais mais sur le fond rien
n'a changé on en est là il faut
reprendre les fondamentaux de ce qui
était le programme Loula refaire manger
à leur fin les 30 millions de Brésiliens
aujourd'hui qui n'y arrivent pas bien
sûr souvent le terme qu'on entend
utiliser en Europe
en France quand on entend ce type de
propos c'est que ce sont des propos
populistes qui parlent au ventre des
gens et pas leurs raisons ça c'est un
regard à mes yeux de personnes qui ne se
rendent pas compte
deux du caractère absolument dramatique
actuellement de la retomber de dizaines
de millions de Brésiliens dans la misère
et dans la malnutrition voir la
dénutrition des populations qui avaient
été sorties par la création très très
modeste d'un État providence qui
permettait l'alimentation la vaccination
des enfants le fait d'avoir de
l'habitation sociale minimale qui sont
les grands programmes sociaux qui ont
été faits sous les gouvernements du pété
qui sont une réalité c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas seulement un discours ça a
changé véritablement des gens et c'est
ce sur quoi Lula doit capitaliser pour
retrouver les classes populaires parce
qu'une partie des classes populaires ont
été happées par le bolsonarisme le
bolsonarisme c'est une extrême droite
qui n'est pas une extrême droite
élitiste bolsonaro avait créé un
personnage avec ses propres origines qui
parlaient aux petits peuple au petit
peuple déçu par la classe politique
déçue par la démocratie qui attendait
quelque chose de nouveau
et quelqu'un qui s'intéresse à leurs
problèmes et Lula doit retrouver ces
gens là ces gens là qui attendent que
lui qui vient de la misère qui porte
dans sa trajectoire de vie la
trajectoire de vie de millions de
personnes qui ont connu l'exode rural
qui ont quitté l'extrême pauvreté pour
aller travailler dans des périphéries ou
la démocratie est assez lointaine et où
il gagne à peine de quoi vivre et le
programme de Lula actuellement et de sa
coalition et de retrouver et de redonner
de la dignité à ces millions de
personnes et la dignité ça commence par
le fait de pouvoir les travailler le
ventre plein et c'est pour ça que c'est
le cœur du programme actuellement du
nouvel exécutif ce programme en
direction des classes les plus
populaires les plus démunis il l'avait
déjà mis en place un certain nombre de
mesures et chacun reconnaît d'ailleurs
qu'il avait réduit la pauvreté à
l'occasion de ces deux points ça je la
présidence du Brésil et c'est à dire que
Jay en 4 ans a réussi à mettre à bas
cette politique sociale chère
aujourd'hui à Lula à nouveau à la tête
du Brésil alors bolsonaro s'en défend et
encore mais la réalité la suivante les
deux mandats de premiers mandat Louna
entre 2002 et 2011 c'est plus de 40
millions de Brésiliens qui ont été
sortis de la pauvreté en fait jamais un
gouvernement brésilien n'avait obtenu de
tels performances si je puis dire dans
ces années 2000 donc c'est ça a été
inconnu pour le Brésil avant Lula de ce
point de vue là notamment avec un
programme social qui est devenu un peu
une légende au Brésil qu'on appelle la
bolza familia qui veut dire la bourse
famille qui est une forme d'allocation
qui est donnée par le gouvernement aux
familles vulnérables aux familles
pauvres ou contre cette allocation les
familles s'engagent à scolariser leur
enfant à les soigner et puis de miser
sur la formation de leurs enfants pour
que la génération d'après puisse être
formé qualifiée et participer finalement
de manière plus optimale si je puis dire
au fonctionnement de la société donc
exactement c'est censeurs sociales la
mobilité sociale qui a organisée à
partir d'une impulsion de politique
publique bon ça ça a été quelque chose
d'inoubliable pour les Brésiliens et qui
explique en partie pourquoi Lula a
quitté le pouvoir en 2011 et plus de 80%
de popularité ça aussi c'était inédit
bolsonaro bah c'est simple le bilan de 4
ans de botswanaro et c'est pas moi qui
vous le dis c'est les Nations unies la
commission économique pour l'Amérique
latine la sépale c'est surtout les
indicateurs de pauvreté d'inégalités
d'informalité c'est à dire de travail au
noir au Brésil et d'insécurité
alimentaire vous parliez des 30 millions
de Brésiliens qui ont faim il y a cela
mais aussi la moitié des Brésiliens qui
sont concernés par une forme ou une
autre d'insécurité alimentaire le Brésil
surtout ses indicateurs c'est simple
c'est le grand bon en arrière il a
reculé entre 20 et 30 ans par rapport à
la situation actuelle donc c'est pour ça
que Lula était le premier à le dire il
dit on me dit que je reviens avec le
programme des vieux jours heureux ça
suffirait pas ce serait pas assez
radical mais Lula disait mais le Brésil
est depuis 30 ans en arrière on doit
reconstruire ce que bolsonaro a détruit
alors si certains veulent un petit peu
dédouané bolsonaro il dirait oui mais
bon depuis il y a eu la crise et la
récession des années 2010 au Brésil
après la crise financière internationale
2008 puis il y a eu le covid 19 qui est
venu là aussi s'abattre sur ce pays qui
a été tellement durement touché c'est
vrai mais la question c'est que comment
bolsonaro a géré tout cela bah le
résultat c'est les indicateurs que je
vous ai donné
700000 morts cette crise du covid au
Brésil ça c'est le résultat de la
gestion de cette crise par Jahia
bolsonaro ça a été déterminant
semble-t-il dans cette élection tout à
fait c'est ce que nous dit ce
documentaire il a le chercheur qui en
parle dans le documentaire c'est très
intéressant parce que tout à fait il a
tout à fait raison le Front républicain
comment qui s'est vraiment
consacré créé c'est à construire autour
de Lula il a été la crise du covid est
passée par là il y a les tétée
déterminante froid bel et qui est beau
Sonal fait partie des antivax il
négationniste de la covid il s'est moqué
des gens qui mouraient
de la covid il disait que les masques ne
servaient rien
c'est vraiment caricatural il est il
disait même que le vaccin allait
transformer les gens un crocodile voilà
pour vous donner une ordre d'idées un
président de la République qui sort
quelques années donc tout pareil donc il
était très responsable de la mort de 700
000 personnes officiellement parce que
les instituts de recherche brésiliens
par le de plus encore que cette cent
mille 700 000 se le centre de santé
nationale le compte de centre de santé
nationale plus des gens qui sont mortes
chez eux qui n'ont pas eu accès il n'a
eu pas le temps d'arriver aux hôpitaux
donc il doit répondre à ces crimes
contre le peuple brésilien bolsona il
doit rentrer au Brésil parce que en ce
moment il est aux États-Unis il est
parti en Floride pas très loin de
Monsieur Trump il est parti en disant
qu'il rentrait le 30 janvier là cette
semaine il a déjà déclaré qu'il repousse
encore d'un mois son séjour aux
États-Unis il doit rentrer au Brésil et
répondre pour ses crimes il y a aussi
une autre question c'est l'influence du
Brésil sur la scène d'abord de
l'Amérique latine
et la scène internationale Obama dans ce
documentaire il y a un extrait où on va
mal le traite de personnage le plus
connu au monde au début des années 2010
quels sont les enjeux de ce point de vue
là concernant Lula est-ce qu'il a la
possibilité de remettre le Brésil un
rang plus convenable pour pour ce pays
les défis sont
innombrables parce que justement le le
pays était effondré et d'une certaine
manière quand j'entends monsieur Ventura
madame Campello on a tous les éléments
qui laissent à penser que c'est un pays
qui a besoin presque d'une transition
démocratique qui sort d'un deuil
collectif massif comme après une guerre
civile qui sort d'un d'une
déconstruction des institutions
démocratiques qui sort d'une explosion
totale de la pauvreté et avec une
population complètement fragmentée et
donc c'est un pays dont on ne comprend
pas de l'étranger qu'il ne vit pas une
alternance politique et donc qu'on
attend de retour sur la scène
internationale comme il avant de devenir
un pari international sous bolsonaro qui
était complètement devenu et en même
temps c'est un pays qui est très attendu
en même temps qu'il doit complètement
se réaffirmer sur des bases
démocratiques de réaffirmer la dignité
de ces populations et c'est ça qui est
compliqué pour pour Loola il est attendu
à l'étranger par sa propre population
alors qu'il a quelque chose de beaucoup
plus compliqué à faire qu'une alternance
et je pense que c'est une grande leçon
pour nous quand le néo fascisme est au
pouvoir après il y a pas d'alternance
après il y a autre chose qui nécessite
de refonder la démocratie et qui
ressemble à une transition démocratique
et donc avec ces contraintes là quelle
marge de manœuvre va avoir lu là pour se
réaffirmer sur la scène internationale
évidemment il a cette ambition là il n'a
cessé de le dire que le monde attendait
le Brésil et voulait retrouver le Brésil
en Amérique latine mais aussi comme
arbitre plus largement sur la scène
internationale il nous reste une minute
il a 77 ans aujourd'hui autrement dit il
y a très fortes chances que ça soit son
dernier acte sur la scène politique
brésilienne cette présidente est-ce
qu'il faut aussi et peut-être surtout
penser à la suite
concernant le Parti des travailleurs qui
est parti d'origine qui a créé là
et des démocrates au Brésil est-ce qu'il
aurait un successeur à désigner ça fait
partie de sa mission à venir aussi à la
tête du Brésil alors ça c'est une
question très ouverte je pense je sais
pas ce que diront
Erika et Maud mais je pense que c'est
vous quoi le mot de la fin
c'est moi qui ai le mot de la fin je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a pas de
successeur à loulac désigné il y a des
leaders qui ont émergé depuis quelques
années depuis la crise qu'on a évoqué
avec dilmar Rousseff il y a Guillaume le
boulot c'est par exemple qui est d'un
parti plus à gauche que le PT qui est
qui s'appelle le Parti socialiste
ouvrier libertaire quelque chose comme
ça le pessol il y a quelques leaders
comme ça qu'on la trentaine 30-40 ans
mais honnêtement aujourd'hui personne
n'a la surface de Lula et c'est une
question ouverte pour l'avenir du pays
alors que effectivement l'autre côté
même si bolsonaro partait ce qui n'est
pas sûr mais le bolsonarisme lui va
rester et donc il va peut-être être
capable de faire sortir un nouveau
leader je n'en sais rien mais en tout
cas aujourd'hui il y a personne qui qui
a la ils ont la stature de de Lula c'est
certain mais il y a plein de mouvements
sociaux ça a été dit au Brésil et qui
sont très dynamiques très revendicative
et il y a des cadres en tout cas qui
existent aujourd'hui et qui émergent au
Brésil il y a dans le gouvernement des
gens qui pourraient jouer un rôle
important je pense à Fernando Adad par
exemple qui est la délicatage de
s'occuper l'économie peut-être que c'est
autour de ces personnalités là que
l'avenir en tout cas du Parti des
travailleurs de Lula réside on le verra
moi je dirais plutôt que aujourd'hui il
a des énormes des femmes leaders élus
depuis tes fédérale qui sont des soins
d'affres descendante soit des femmes
autochtones qui ont une force énorme qui
ont quatre ans et Lou là il a 7 on va
dire cette obligation de penser le
Brésil l'avenir du Brésil après ces
quatre ans et il faut vraiment donner
plus de puissance et plus de espaces et
place pour des femmes qui ont toute la
capacité pour gouverne le Brésil pour
les années à venir vous aurez tout de
même le mot de la fin merci vraiment à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat doc aujourd'hui consacré à Lula
après le documentaire signé José
Bourgarel qui nous a dépeint ce parcours
formidable extraordinaire de Lula qui
c'est vrai recoupe aussi l'histoire de
son pays pendant trois quarts de siècle
vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag des
Badoc sur Twitter merci à celle massali
qui va comme à l'accoutumé aider à
préparer cette émission et je vous
retrouve pour un prochain débat doc et
ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]